- Darryl,
I looked my woman in the eye sockets.
I told her straight out.
I just said it man.
I said it.
I said, I said, I said . . .
I said "bi..."
- Hey guys.
- Hey girl.
- Oh hey, how you doing?
Man, you having a good time?
You see the bedroom up there?
Did you see that washing machine?
- I was just looking at the water.
- That washing machine is huge.
You get a whole bunch of
clothes in that washing machine.
- Yeah, baby.
I'm gonna take her back up to the kitchen
and show her the dishwasher.
- Darryl?
- Yeah, baby.
- I want a kitchen island
just like the one upstairs.
- You gonna get it too.
- I love you.
- I said, "biiiitch,
if you wanted to go to Taylor's,
just tell a brother you want
to go to go to Taylor's, okay?"
(rhythmic beatboxing)
- Because you're my wife
and you love the theater,
and it's your birthday.
Great.
Unfortunately the
orchestra's already filled up
but they do have seats that are still left
in the dress circle.
So if you want to me to get
them theater tickets right now,
I'm gonna do it right now.
- What's up dog?
I'm about five minutes away.
- Yeah. Okay, yeah.
Cool, no, they're all good singers.
They all good singers.
- Yeah, son.
Nah man, I'm about-
I'm telling you man, I'm
about to cross the street man.
- Nah, they got that one dude
in it that you love, man.
He gonna be in it, yeah.
- Come on man. You know I'm
almost there, all right?
- No, I'm gonna pick your up at 6:30 then.
Cool. Cool.
All right.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
The parking is, the parking is free.
So they got that on lock.
- Oh my god, Christian,
I almost totally just
got mugged right now.
(presidential orchestra music)
- Good evening, my fellow Americans.
Now, before I begin, I just wanna say,
that I know a lot of people
out there seem to think that
I don't get angry.
That's just not true.
I get angry a lot.
It's just that the way I express passion,
is different from most.
So just so there's no more confusion,
we've hired Luther here
to be my anger translator.
Luther.
- Hi.
- First off, concerning
the recent developments
in the Middle Eastern region,
I just wanna reiterate
our unflinching support
for all people and their
right to a democratic process.
- Hey, all y'all dictators out there,
keep messing around and see what happens.
Just see what happens.
Watch.
- Also, to the governments
of Iran and North Korea,
we once again urge you
to discontinue your
uranium enrichment program.
- Hey, Mahmood, Kim Jong,
I think I already done told both y'all,
86 your (beep) bitches,
or I'ma come over there
and do it for y'all.
Please test me and see what happens.
- On the domestic front,
I just wanna say to my critics,
I hear your voices and I'm
aware of your concerns.
- So maybe you can chill the hell out
for like a second then maybe
I can focus on some (beep).
You know.
- That goes for everybody,
including members of the Tea party.
- Oh, don't even get me started
on these (beep) right here.
- I wanna assure you
that we will be looking
for new compromises with the
GOP and the months ahead.
- And you know these (beep)
gonna say no before I
even suggest some (beep).
- Now, I know that a lot of folks say
that I haven't done a good job
at communicating my
accomplishments to the public
- Because y'all (beep) don't listen.
- Since being in office, we've
created 3 million new jobs.
- 3 million new jobs.
- We ended the war in Iraq.
- Ended the war y'all.
We ended a war. Remember that?
- These achievements should serve
as a reminder that I am on your side.
- I'm not a Muslim
- And that my intentions
as your president are
coming from the right place.
- They're coming from Hawaii,
which is where I'm from
which is in the United States of America.
Y'all okay?
This is ridiculous.
I have a birth certificate.
I have a hot diggity-doggity,
Mama Say Mama Sa Mama
Coosa, birth certificate.
You dumbass crackers.
- Okay, Luther?
- Yep.
- Rope it in.
- Dial it back Luther, damn.
- In conclusion,
last night I had a
conversation with Michelle.
- I says, bitch.
- Nope, I did not say that.
I did not say that.
- Excuse me,
I think we're ready to order.
- Well, I'm sorry.
That's not how things work
in this establishment.
Someone will come to you.
- Yes, we're sorry.
No, no problem.
- What was that?
- What?
- Well, where was black Jeff?
- Black Jeff, what?
- Yeah, black Jeff.
I read somewhere that when
you dated a biracial guy
you're supposed to get
the best of both worlds.
So there are white Jeff situations
and there are black Jeff situations.
And that was definitely
a black Jeff situation.
- Oh, okay.
- Hi folks,
I'm so sorry for the wait.
Can I get you bottled
or tap water for the table this evening?
- How about I bottle your
and kick it down the stairs?
Man, we've been waiting half an hour
for one of you (beep) to show up.
- God, I'm so sorry I,
I'll get you a bottle
of our finest premium water on the house.
- That's what I said bitch.
- Sorry, what are you doing?
- Black Jeff.
That was black Jeff.
- But he was just trying to help us.
- Oh, so white Jeff?
- Yes.
- Good evening.
I'm sorry to bother you two.
I am the Maitre D here at Chez Henri.
- Oh yes, what is it?
- I am so sorry to disturb you both.
But our establishment
has a certain dress code
and madame's decolletage is inappropriate.
- Oh my God.
We are very sorry.
We, we didn't know there was a dress code.
We'll certainly remember for the next time
but there ain't going
be no next time for you.
Looking at my woman
and her, deco-chocolat,
or whatever you said, man.
- Is there a problem here?
- Okay see, it was really
a simple misunderstanding.
It all started with
that (beep) right there
who was disrespecting myself and my girl.
But we really love this guy
and he gave us exceptional service.
- We are gonna have to ask you to leave.
- You have to ask me to leave.
Oh, you gonna have to ask
the black man to leave, huh?
Actually, you don't
have to ask us to leave.
Wanna see ourselves out
and we ain't never coming back again,
though we really appreciate your help.
That's it-
(plates crashing)
(speaking Spanish)
Watch your ass man!
Let us reimburse you
for that breakage okay?
Right after I burn this whole
place to the (beep) ground
with everybody inside of it.
By which I mean,
you're gonna get a very
negative review on Yelp.
(school bell ringing)
- Mrs. Brown is like
the most (muffled by bell ringing)
teacher I've seen in my life.
You know what I mean?
(instrumental hip hop music)
Why you reading bitch?
- Because I like to read and
this is a really good book.
- You're a really good bitch,
bitch.
- Why you gotta bother me man?
- Because,
I'm not doing very well at school.
I'm reading at a third grade level.
I really don't want to get left back.
So when I see somebody reading for fun
it makes me feel that much more stupid.
And then I get mad.
- I didn't know that.
Thanks so much for opening up to me.
- Shut up queer.
- I don't understand why.
I mean, why you gotta go there?
- I've been having sexual fantasies
about some of the other guys at school.
- What?
- Gimme that.
I'm afraid of these feelings
and what they might mean.
It's like, because I hate myself so much
I gotta point that hate
outward towards you (laughs).
- You understand this on
such a deep level that-
- I don't understand.
Now I'm gonna punish you physically
for acknowledging my emotional problems.
- Wait! I was gonna say,
if you understand yourself so well
then maybe you should try
working on changing it.
- Of course I want to change it,
but it's the only defense mechanism I have
against deeper more terrifying
problems buried inside of me.
(wheels screeching to a halt)
(general crowd chatter)
You're lucky my dad's here.
(dad banging door)
- Get in the damn truck son.
I need to take you home and
beat on you 'cause I hate myself
and you look like your mother who left me.
And I'm gonna block out the guilt I feel
over mistreating you
with a river of vodka.
(somber piano music)
- I'm gonna internalize that
and unknowingly transfer
it onto you tomorrow.
(piano music continues)
I'm coming reluctantly.
(piano music fades out)
- Carvell, thank you for coming. (sighs)
First order of business,
I'm sure y'all heard
that Twigs got pulled out
the river this morning.
There ain't no secret,
he and Carvell grew up
in the hood together.
Listen up.
Carvell, about to say some words.
(dramatic music)
(Carvell whimpering)
- Okay, know what?
Don't none of you,
look at them tears and
think that (beep) is funny,
because it takes a big man
to cry in front of his crew.
Go ahead Carvell.
(Carvell sniffling)
- Y'all know Twig was my boy.
Back in the day,
we used to pretend the
sofa cushions was a fort
and we used to pretend that
the floor was molten lava.
- Okay, you know what though?
Ain't nothing funny about that.
Of course this man is crying,
'cause he and twigs was kids together.
Okay. You know, I mean they
best friends forever and (beep).
Go ahead, Carvell.
- We used to play Care Bears.
- Mmhm.
- Twigs and I would spend
the good part of an afternoon
trying to figure out
which care bear we was.
- Oh, oh.
I wish one of y'all (beep)
would just start laughing,
because y'all know you
think this (beep) is funny.
Carvell over here blubbering
and talking about Care Bears.
But you know what?
But you-
Those are manly tears, okay?
Those are some manly
ass tears right there,
that you looking at.
Go ahead Carvell.
- And then, (whimpering).
- Aha!
Oh, sorry man, that was a weird ass sneeze
I just did right there.
God damn it, can the
brother get some (beep)
Claritin up in here?
Go ahead, Carvell.
- Twigs always fancied himself Share Bear.
(crew member stifling laughter)
I always, I always thought,
thought of myself as
more of a Funshine Bear.
- Okay. Okay.
All you need to respect that right there.
Okay? Y'all need to listen
to Funshine (laughs).
I'm sorry. (laughs harder)
I'm sorry man.
You a Funshine Bear man.
I'm sorry that that is some funny (beep).
(gun shot banging)
- Whoa, whoa.
- Alright, let's go sell some crack.
(doorbell ringing)
- Hey, hey, hey.
- Hey.
- Hi sweetie, that's for you.
Hi.
- Check out the house.
- Oh my.
- Girl, I got a sunken
tub you gotta see it.
- Oh, I got to see this.
- You two have a good time now.
- Have fun, have fun.
(both chuckling)
- Dude, I am sorry we're late
- Man, it happens man.
- And she talk about
how we're supposed to
be in the car at 6:45.
I'm like, all right.
- Uh-oh.
- Tell me my dumbass
ain't sitting in the car
waiting until 7:15.
- Uh uh.
- Okay, when I track my
wife down 20 minutes later
she's stepping out the damn shower,
talking about "can I help you?"
- See, that's crazy right there.
- Craig, I looked this woman
in the eye, I said. . .
"Bitch, you told me 6:45".
- You said that?
- Pssh. Yeah, I said . . .
"Bitch", then I laid it out.
- But you said though bitch though?
- Hmm?
- You said bitch?
- Yeah.
- [Craig's Wife] You
gotta see the fireplace
downstairs in the living room.
- [Darryl's Wife] Okay.
- Don't play games man.
Just tell me what you gonna tell me.
- Exactly,
It's like say what you
mean, mean what you say.
- Is that so hard?
- It's like last week, man,
we going out to dinner.
Right? I'm like, "Where
do you want to go?"
She's like, "You decide."
- Uh-oh.
- I'm like, "All right,
Outback Steakhouse."
She like, "nah."
I'm like, "Straight up, Chili's."
She's like, "Eh."
- No, no.
- Darryl, I named seven more restaurants.
No, Craig. No.
- I finally said, "Taylor's",
the place I know she wants
to go in the first place.
- Right! Right.
- She look at me, she said,
"If that's where you want to go."
- No she didn't, Craig.
- If that's where I want to go?
Darryl, I looked my
woman in the eye sockets.
I told her straight out.
I just said it, man.
I said it.
I said, I said, I said . . .
I said "bi-
- Hey guys.
- Hey girl.
- Oh hey, how you doing?
Man, you having a good time?
You see the bedroom up there?
Did you see that washing machine?
- I was just looking at the water.
- That washing machine is huge.
You get a whole bunch of
clothes in that washing machine.
- Yeah, baby.
I'm gonna take her back up to the kitchen
and show her the dishwasher.
- Darryl?
- Yeah, baby.
- I want a Kitchen Island
just like the one upstairs.
- You gonna get it too.
- I love you.
- I said "Bitch
if you wanted to go to Taylor's,
just tell a brother you
want To go to Taylor's."
- You said that?
- Oh hell yeah, man.
I laid it out.
Right? I says, I says, I says. . .
I said, "Bitch, I'm the man of the house.
- You said bitch though?
- Hmm?
- You called your wife a bitch?
- Uh yeah.
- [Craig's Wife] Craig?
- [Darryl's Wife] Darryl?
- [Craig's Wife] Where are those guys?
- [Darryl's Wife] I don't know.
- [Craig's Wife] Girl,
let me show you this.
- [Darryl] So she's like,
"Why don't you rent a movie we both like?"
- [Craig] Like, no she didn't.
- After I spent 25 minutes
in the god damn Blockbuster, Craig.
I looked this woman in her optic stems,
and I says. . .
I says-
(hawk screeching)
I says, "Bitch."
- You said that?
- Ain't nothing but a thing.
- Oh, wait, but you said bitch though?
- Yep.
(phone ringing)
Hey honey, Craig just gave
me the neighborhood tour.
- So then she's like,
"I didn't know we'd be
doing so much walking."
- Nuh-uh.
- I'm like, "I didn't tell
you to wear those shoes."
She said, "Don't raise your voice at me."
- What?
- Darryl,
I looked this woman dead
in the windows of her soul.
I said. . .
(ship door closing)
(knocking on window)
I said "biiiitch."
(rhythmic acapella music)
♪ All I want yeah ♪
♪ But I know me ♪